the river is behind them they've been
processed by U.S border Patrol and now
they're released to a shelter run by a
local NGO
here we find Jefferson makana and his
family of four he says he couldn't keep
his children fed in Venezuela so they
left home traveling one month to reach
the United States
he almost died while crossing the Rio
Grande his wife says
he started convulsing from a heart
condition and collapsed on the U.S Shore
he says American Medics revived him and
he's grateful
as makana joins the shelter's line for
food he shows us the electric monitor
immigration officials cuffed onto his
ankle this was a condition of his
release to ensure he'll turn up later
when summoned now away from his wife and
kids his confidence cracks
he hates it he says it makes him feel
like a criminal and he isn't one
the monitor prohibits him from leaving
his registered address in the U.S for
longer than an hour making it impossible
to work he left Venezuela because he
couldn't support his family there he
fears he won't be able to support them
here either
under informed the shelter's director
says many families share the
disappointment most of them believe that
they are coming and they're going to be
able to do to work so they come
motivated by life
the shelter focuses on the migrants
immediate needs a sandwich fresh clothes
and a place to patch up wounds the
border is lined with razor wire mostly
Cuts in their arms and feet and legs and
the shelter offers a place for families
to wait for transportation to distant
U.S cities most will stay with relatives
as the government decides their
immigration cases most and in
deportation orders buses that have been
sent here by the state of Texas are now
picking up people
a policewoman and her dog perform a
final scam before the bus leaves it's
unclear what could possibly be hidden
besides those tucked away worries as
they drive off toward an uncertain
future
Heidi Joe Castro Al Jazeera Eagle Pass
Texas
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera